brad
what are you doing hi doctor and thank
you for taking the time to answer these
21 questions
no problem welcome to the art barn come
on in let's start off with what did you
have for breakfast this morning
well it's over 100 degrees in california
right now but i decided to go with hot
chocolate today
and banana bread even though i'm
allergic to bananas how did you travel
to school today
definitely in my car how long is the
distance from your front door here
being probably about 23 miles
what's your mindset when you enter
school every day i think just pretty
basic
i just want people to have a good day
when they come and when they leave just
a good day
that's good what's one thing you love
about your area in school
i think because it's small it's a small
school so we have a really good fun
family community vibe
now some fun facts who's your favorite
movie star
i'm torn between denzel washington and
sandra bullock
who's your favorite singer abandoned
right now i'm into
colon he's from hawaii and kahloe kai
from hawaii too
who would you consider your heroes
that's definitely my mom
daddy my mom she's amazing what's the
one place you would love to visit
definitely bora bora the french
what was your favorite subject i'd have
to say math
love math love numbers what was your
least favorite subject
history history no no history
what kind of student were you in school
i think it'd be best if my teachers or
my parents answered that question but
i'd like to think that i was a very good
student
um in school and a pretty good kid i
think if you were to eat lunch at school
in the cafeteria what would your
favorite food be
probably not a food item here but um i
would definitely have sarah slushies
they're really good they have really
good splashes
what time do you usually leave school
every day it's usually dark
so at night time it's definitely dark do
you continue working when you get home
as well
always always working always creating
always doing things
what do you do when you relax anything
with adrenaline
what are your passions and hobbies
outside of teaching travel
always travel what's your proudest
achievement as a teacher
i think the art barn and creating the
art expo because we're able to work with
all of my colleagues
all of my students in our community to
create a really cool art show
if you could write one motivational
quote on your blog what would it be
oh gosh well it's actually on the board
so let's check it out
so i have my philosophy with my kids all
the time and it's do more today
and always to enjoy the ride always
what's one of your
important things you would tell your
students i think for them to find their
why find their passion
and when they do just go for it fresh
i have to tell you this is rachel but
her name is
captain ranch and lastly why did you
become a teacher
i think for me i initially trained to
save lives in one week so i wanted to
save lives in a different way and
teaching allowed me to do that
that's it thank you for having us today
no problem we'll be here for you have
fun
thank you